je voudrais être sûr qu'on se comprenne
alors qu'entendez vous par se lancer
je parle d'aller voir ailleurs de
coucher avec d'autres partenaires
vous avez l'air un peu surpris callas
[Musique]
reiss étaient déjà rentrés
j'avais mon pantalon dieu je suis en
train d'essayer de t d on peut changer
de sujet mais kimono colis c'est dingue
et vous avez vu ce mec porter new
balance lagarde pas de doute on a fait
un vrai coureur
[Musique]
ah bon et je trouvais que tout se
passait bien a encore le temps mais
reste le dessert notre carte et de la
santé sens tu vas apprendre à s'affirmer
j'adorais forme dans le monde du jeu
justement envoyer en l'air avec une
inconnue
ok je peux vous offrir une finition
manuelle part je veux avoir des enfants
je sais que mon petit ami vient de
plaquer j'aime mieux comme ça tu
trembles
[Musique]
tu as raison dans ce domaine on s'en
tire plutôt mal il faut que tu lui
annonce simplement ils peuvent
surprendre du coup c'est pas vrai mais
béthune puis sort c'est parce yeux
mais tout ce qui compte c'est qu'on a
vécu dans cette veine et qu'on arrive si
tu te demandes ce qui se passera grand
coq ans verra demain allenby c'est une
vraie question
[Musique]
tu vas trouver ça dingue mais mais j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] en valeur
[Musique]